hello everyone and welcome to some very
disturbing news from the chess world uh
you are probably wondering why i'm using
this format instead of the usual one
well it's the one i use when i have some
very very urgent news and this one is uh
most urgent magnus carlsen will not be
defending his style of world champion uh
against the ani pognishi next year uh he
announced it today on on a podcast um it
was called the the magnus effect um for
his sponsor
unibet and uh it's something that
everyone thought was a bluff but magnus
carlsen did say that unless alireza
firuja wins the uh candidates tournament
that he will not be playing and even
though everyone thought it was uh it was
a joke that you know
what are the chances that he he will not
play for the for a wheelchair
championship title uh it seems that uh
he was telling the truth all along he
says that he just doesn't have all that
much to gain and that uh
he will not be retiring of course he
will still be playing chess he will
still uh be uh heading towards that goal
of hitting the 2900 uh classical rating
he will still play uh
all the other tournaments but i think uh
most of that he is just bored with the
format it's um he considers it a very uh
old-fashioned form of just so many
classical games and it takes months of
preparation for the world's championship
match and even for uh even though for us
the viewers it's uh like the the
absolute highlight of the year of of
every two years as the we have one year
the candidates turn in the next year the
world championship match uh it seems
that uh it's just too much of a hassle
for him and that uh well i i think he
just doesn't think that it will uh be
relevant for for very long because
younger players now don't really enjoy
classical that much they play a lot more
bullet a lot more blitz a lot more rapid
and that if there should be a world
chess championship
well or some sort of a
highest tier
challenge or a tournament uh that it
should include all formats maybe like a
few few games of classical also rapid
also blitz maybe even end with an
armageddon
but
definitely not um i don't know 12 games
of classical or even they considered
increasing it to 14 or maybe 16 uh or
let alone how they did it in the older
days uh even more than that like 24 or
or whatnot uh so that's pretty much the
news i'm very much interested as usual
what you guys have to say about this
it's um it's sort of an end of an era
but uh
yeah
you know it would be it would be
terrible if magnus decided not to play
all together uh but we'll still be
seeing a whole lot of magnus so uh
it's it's not a as as as bad uh but i i
think it will yeah i don't know it will
leave a sour taste
for whoever wins the world championship
title because now of course yanni
palmishi will be playing against being
liran uh who uh won second place in the
in the candidates tournament um and it
will not be as as prestigious as taking
away the world chess championship title
wave from magnus carlsen himself uh he's
been world champion since uh 2013 since
he's taken the title away from
vishwanathan anand and uh he's been the
highest rated player for over a decade
now he's been uh
i think he's been over 2800 for for over
a decade
ever since he
breached 2800 he never uh
went below that because everyone other
than magnus carlsen they went into the
2800 club stayed there a little bit and
then they dropped out but now uh as i'm
making this video only only magnus and
the ding are in the 2800 club nipple is
very very close so it will be yanni
palmishi versus being lyran for the
world chess championship match title uh
next year uh and the magnus will not be
playing
maybe he changes his mind at some point
maybe he
gives up the title now and then decides
to rejoin the candidates tournament some
in some other cycle uh and then maybe he
goes through it all over again but i
guess i don't know if he decided not to
do it now then i think that that's the
decision that he will stick with
and um yeah that's uh that's pretty much
it uh so uh yeah what do you guys think
about that and what does this mean for
the chess world altogether uh we'll see
uh the future of chess is very uncertain
at the moment
so yeah thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day